the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello everybody some announcements the
last reading assignment of the semester
at least from us
course evaluations are still available
through this this Friday but only till
noon again I urge you all to do it and
then finally for the final exam we're
going to be giving you some code to
study and advance to the exam and then
we will ask questions about that code on
the exam itself this was described in
the announcement for the exam and we
will be making this code available later
today now I would suggest that you try
and get your heads around it if you're
confused that's a good thing to talk
about in office hours to get some help
with it as opposed to waiting till 20
minutes before the exam and realizing
you're confused all right I want to pick
up where we left off on Monday so you
may recall that we were comparing
results of KNN and logistic regression
on our Titanic data and we had this up
using 10 8020 splits for K N equals 3
and logistic regression with P equals
0.5 and what I observed is that logistic
regression happened to perform slightly
better but certainly nothing that you
would choose to write home about right
it's it's a little bit better that isn't
to say we'll always be better happens to
be here but the point I closed with is
one of the things we care about when we
use machine learning is not only our
ability to make predictions with the
model but what can we learn by studying
the model itself remember the idea is
that the model is somehow capturing the
system or the process that
generated the data and by studying the
model we can learn something useful so
to do that for logistic regression we
begin by looking at the weights of the
different variables and we had this up
and the last slide the model classes are
died and survived for the labels
survived we said that if you were in a
first class cabin that have a positive
impact on your survival a pretty strong
positive impact
you can't interpret these weights in and
of themselves if I said it's one point
six that really doesn't mean anything so
what you have to look at is the relative
weights not the absolute weights and we
see that it's a pretty strong relative
wait a second class cabin also has a
positive weight in this case of 0.46
so it was indicating you met had better
than average chance of surviving but
much less strong than the first class
and if you were one of those poor people
in a third class cabin well that had a
negative weight on survival you were
less likely to survive H had a very
small effect here slightly negative what
that meant is the older you were the
less likely you were to have survived
but it's a very small negative value
male gender had a very large relatively
large negative gender suggesting that if
you were a male you were more likely to
die than if you are a female this might
be true in the general population but it
was especially true on the Titanic
finally I warned you that while what I
just went through is something you will
read in lots of papers that use machine
learning you will hear and lots of talk
about people have used machine learning
but you should be very wary when people
speak that way it's not nonsense
but some cautionary notes in particular
there's a big issue because the features
are often correlated with one another
and so you can't interpret the weights
one feature at a time to get a little
bit technical there are two major ways
people use logistic regression they're
called l1 and l2 we used an l2 I'll come
back to that in a minute because that's
the default in in in Python or psych it
you can set that parameter at l2 and do
that tail one if you want I experimented
with it it didn't change the results
that much but what an l1 regression is
designed to do is to find some weights
and drive them to zero this is
particularly useful when you have a very
high dimensional problem relative to the
number of examples and this gets back to
that question we've talked about many
times of overfitting if you've got a
thousand variables and a thousand
examples you're very likely to overfit
l2 l1 is designed to avoid overfitting
by taking many of those thousand
variables and just giving them zero
weight and it does typically generalize
better but if you have two variables
that are correlated l1 will drive one to
zero and it will look like it's
unimportant but in fact it might be
important it's just correlated with
another which has gotten all the credit
l2 which is what we did does the
opposite it spreads the way to cross the
variables so if you have a bunch of
correlated variables it might look like
none of them are very important because
each of them get
a small amount of the weight again not
so important when you have four or five
variables is what I'm showing you but it
matters when you have a hundred or
thousand variables let's look at an
example
so the cabin classes the way we set it
up C 1 plus C 2 plus C 3 whoops is not
equal to zero what is it equal to I'll
fix this right now
what should that have said what's the
invariant here well a person it is in
exactly one class right I guess if
you're really rich maybe you rented two
cabins one in first and one in second
but probably not or if you did you put
your servants in second or third but
what does this got to add up to yeah has
to add up to 1 thank you so it adds up
to 1 ooh got his attention at least all
right so what this tells us is the
values are not independent because if C
1 is 1 then C 2 and C 3 must be 0 right
and so now we could go back to the
previous slide and ask the question well
is it that being in first class is
protective or is it that being in second
or third class is risky and there's no
simple answer to that so let's do an
experiment we have these correlated
variables suppose we eliminate C 1
altogether so I did that by changing the
anit method of class passenger takes the
same argument but now look at the code
good because it's a little bit clearer
there so there was the original one and
I'm going to replace that by this
comment out the original one so what you
see is that instead of having five
features I now have four I've eliminated
the C one binary feature and then the
code is is straightforward that I've
just come through here and I've just
enumerated the possibilities so if
you're in first class then for second
and third or both zero otherwise one of
them is one some land variant is is gone
now right it's not the case that we know
that these two things have to add up to
one because maybe I'm in the third case
okay let's go run that code and see what
happens
well if you remember we see that our
accuracy has not really declined much
pretty much the same results we got
before but our weights are really quite
different
now suddenly c2 and c3 have large
negative weights we can look at them
side by side here
so you see not much difference it
actually performs maybe mail really no
real difference in performance but
you'll notice that the weights are
really quite different that now what had
been a strong positive weight and
relatively weak negative weights is now
replaced by too strong negative weights
and age and gender change just a little
bit so the whole point here is we have
to be very careful when you have
correlated features about over
interpreting the weights it is generally
pretty safe to rely on the sign whether
it's negative or positive all right
changing the topic but sticking with
logistic regression there is this
parameter you may recall P which is the
probability and that was the cutoff and
we set it to 0.5 saying if it estimates
the probability of survival to be 0.5 or
higher then we're going to guess
survived predict survived otherwise
deceased
you can change that and so I'm going to
try two extreme values setting P to
point one and P two point nine now what
do we think that's likely to change
remember we looked at a bunch of
different attributes in particular what
attributes we think are most likely to
change anyone who has not answered a
question want to volunteer I have
nothing against you it's just I'm trying
to spread the wealth and I don't want to
give you diabetes to all the candy all
right you get to go again
Partin sensitivity and specificity
positive predictive value right because
we're shifting and we're saying well by
changing the probability we're inclining
we're making a decision that it's more
important to not miss survivors than it
is to say esque gets too high so let's
look at what happens when we run that I
won't run it for you but these are the
results we got so as it happens point 9
gave me higher accuracy but the key
thing is notice the big difference here
so what is that telling me well it's
telling me that if I predict you're
going to survive you probably did but
look what it did to the sensitivity
right it means that most of the
survivors I'm predicting they died why
is the accuracy still okay well because
most people died on the boat on the ship
right so we would have done pretty well
you recall if we just gues died for
everybody so it's important to
understand these things I once did some
work using machine learning for an
insurance company who's trying to set
rates and they I asked them what they
wanted to do and they said they wanted
it to they didn't want to lose money
they didn't want to ensure people were
going to get in accidents so I was able
to change this P parameter so that it
did a great job the problem was they got
to write almost no policies because I
could pretty much guarantee the people I
said wouldn't get in an accident
wouldn't but there were a whole bunch of
people who didn't who
they wouldn't write policies for so they
ended up not making any money it was a
bad decision
all right so we can change the cutoff
that leads to a really important concept
of something called the receiver
operating characteristic and it's a
funny name having to do with it
originally going back to radios radio
receivers but we can ignore that the
goal here is to say suppose I don't want
to make a decision about where the
cutoff is but I want to look at in some
sense all possible cut-offs and sort of
look at the shape of it and that's what
this code is designed to do so the way
it works is I'll take a training set and
a test set the usual thing I'll build
one model and that's an important thing
that there's only one model getting
built and then I'm going to vary P and
I'm going to call apply model with the
same model in the same test set but
different peds and keep track of all of
those results I'm then going to plot the
two dimensional plot the y axis will
have sensitivity and the x axis will
have 1 minus specificity
alright so I am accumulating a bunch of
results and then I'm going to produce
this curve calling SK learn metrics dot
AUC that's not the curve AUC stands for
area under the curve and we'll see why
we want to get that area under the curve
okay when I run that it produces this so
here's the curve the blue line there's
some things to note about it way down at
this end I can have zero right you know
I can set it so that I don't make any
predictions so I can be and Way and this
end is interesting so what this end is
saying what remember that my x-axis is
not specificity but 1 minus specificity
right so what we see is this corner is
highly sensitive and very unspecific so
I'll get a lot of false positives this
corner is very specific because 1 minus
specificity is 0 and very insensitive
right so way down at the bottom I'm
declaring nobody to be positive and way
up here
everybody clearly I don't want to be at
either these places on the curve right
typically I want to be somewhere in the
middle and here maybe we can see there's
a nice knee in the curve here
we can choose a place what does this
green line represent do you think the
green line represents a random
classifier I flip a coin and I just
classify something positive or negative
depending on the heads or tails in this
case right so now we can look at an
interesting region which is this region
the area between the curve and a random
classifier and that sort of tells me how
much better I am than random I can look
at the whole area the area under the
curve and that's this the area under the
receiver operating curve in the best of
all worlds the curve would be shaped
like yeah it would be one right that
would be a perfect classifier and the
worst of all worlds it would be zero but
it's never zero because we don't do
worse than 0.5 right we hope not to do
worse than random if so we just reverse
our predictions and then we're better
than random so random is as bad as you
can do really and so this is a very
important concept and it lets us
evaluate how good a classifier is
independently of what we choose to be
the cutoff so that's when you read the
literature and people say I had this
wonderful method of making predictions
you'll almost always see them cite the
AU ROC
all right any questions about this if so
or about machine learning in general if
so this would be a good time to ask them
since I'm about to totally change the
topic yes right so the question is at
what point does the au ROC become
statistically significant and that is
essentially an unanswerable question
look relay it back needed to put more
air under the throw I look like a
quarterback for the Rams any rate he saw
them on them play lately so if you ask
this question about significance it will
depend upon a number of things so you're
always asking is it significantly better
than X right and so the question is a
significantly better than random and you
can't just say for example the point six
is isn't and point seven is because it
depends how many points you have the
more points if you have a lot of points
it could be only a tiny bit better than
point five and still be statistically
significant it may be uninterestingly
better it may not be significant in the
English sense but you still get
statistical significance so that's a
problem and studies have lots of points
in general it depends upon the
application for a lot of applications
you'll see things in the point sevens
being considered pretty useful and the
real question is shouldn't be with it
significant or whether it's useful can
you make useful decisions based upon it
and the other thing is typically when
you're talking about that you're
selecting some point
and really talking about a region
relative to that point you know we
usually don't really care what it does
out here because we hardly ever operate
out there anyway right we're usually
somewhere in the middle good good
question
yeah why are we doing one - specificity
instead of specificity is that the
question and the answer is essentially
so we can do this trick of computing the
area it gives us this nice curve konkey
that's nice if you will
concave curve which lets us compute this
area under here nicely if you were to
take specificity and just draw it it
would wouldn't it would look different
it just really obviously mathematically
there in some sense the same right if
you have 1 minus X and X you can get
either from the other so it really just
has to do with the way people want to
draw this picture pardon does it not
well you'd have to use a different
statistic right you couldn't cite the AU
ROC if you did specificity directly
right which is why they do one - right
the goal is you want to have this point
at 0 and this point 0 0 and 1 1 and
playing 1 - gives you this trick of
anchoring those two points and so then
you get a curve connecting them which
you can then easily compare to the
random curve right it's just one of
these little tricks that statisticians
like to play to make things easy to
visualize and easy to compute statistics
about it's not a fundamental the
important issue anything else
all right so I told you I was going to
change topics finally got one completed
and I am and this is a topic I approach
with some reluctance so you probably all
heard this expression that there are
three kinds of lies lies damned lies and
statistics we've been talking a lot
about statistics and now I want to spend
the rest of today's lecture and the
start of next of Wednesday's lecture
talking about how to lie with statistics
so at this point I usually put on my
numbers never lie hat but do say that
numbers never lie but Liars use numbers
and I hope none of you will ever go work
for a politician and put this knowledge
to bad use this quote is well known it's
variously attributed often to Mark Twain
the fellow on the Left he claimed not to
have invented it but said it was
invented by a Benjamin Disraeli and I
prefer to believe that since it does
seem like something a Prime Minister
would invent so let's think about this
the issue here is the way the human mind
works and statistics Daryl Huff a well
known statistician who did write a book
called how to lie with statistics says
if you can't prove what you want to
prove demonstrate something else and
pretend they're the same thing in the
days that follows the collision of
Statistics with the human mind hardly
anyone will notice the difference
and indeed empirically he seems to be
right so let's look at some examples
here's one I like this is from another
famous set statistician called Anne stem
is and he invented this thing called an
screams quartet I take my hat off now
it's too hot in here a bunch of numbers
eleven XY pairs I know you don't want to
look at the numbers so here are some
statistics about them each of those
pairs has the same mean value for X the
same mean for Y the same variance for X
the same variance for Y and then I went
I fit a linear regression model to it
and lo and behold I got the same
equation for every one y equals 0.5 X
plus 3 so that raises the question if we
go back is a really much difference
between these these pairs of x and y are
they really similar and the answer is
that's what they look like if you plot
them so even though statistically they
appear to be kind of the same they could
hardly be more different right those are
not the same distributions so there's an
important moral here which is that
statistics about data is not the same
thing as the data itself and this seems
obvious but it's amazing how easy it is
to forget it
the number of papers I've read where I
see a bunch of statistics about the data
but don't see the data is enormous and
it's easy to lose track of the fact that
the statistics don't tell the whole
story so the answer is the old Chinese
proverb a picture is worth a thousand
words I urge you the first thing you
should do when you get a data set is
plot it if it's got too many points to
plot all the points subsample it and
plot a subsample use some visualization
tool to look at the data itself now that
said pictures are wonderful but you can
lie with pictures so here's an
interesting chart these are grades
six triple zero one by gender so the
males are blue in the females or pink
sorry for being such a traditionalist
and as you can see the women did way
better than the men now I know for some
of you this is confirmation bias you say
of course others say impossible but in
fact if you look carefully you'll see
that's not what this chart says it all
because if you look at the axis here
you'll see that actually there's not
much difference here's what I get if I
plot it from zero to five yeah the women
did a little bit better but that's not a
statistically significant difference and
by the way when I plotted last year for
six triple o2i the blue was about that
much higher than the pink don't read
much into either of them but the trick
was here I took the y-axis and ran it
from three point nine to four point oh
five I cleverly chose my baseline in
such a way to make the difference look
really big much bigger than it is here I
did the honest thing of put the baseline
at zero and run it to five because
that's the range of grades at MIT and so
when you look at a chart it's important
to keep in mind that you need to look at
the axis labels and the scales let's
look at another chart just in case you
think I'm the only one who likes to play
with graphics this is a chart from Fox
News and they're arguing here there's a
shocking statistics that there are a
hundred and eight point six million
people on welfare an 101.7 with a
full-time job and you can imagine the
rhetoric that accompanies this chart
this is actually correct it's from it is
true from the Census Bureau data sort of
but notice that I said you should read
the labels on the axes there is no label
here so but you can bet that the
y-intercept is not zero on this right
because you can see how small one one
hundred and one point seven looks like
so it makes the difference look bigger
than it is now
that's not the only funny thing about it
I said you should look at the labels on
the x-axis
well they've labeled them but what are
these things mean well I looked it up I
will tell you what they actually mean
people on welfare counts the number of
people in a household in which at least
one person is on welfare so if there is
a two parents one is working in one is
collecting welfare and there are four
kids that counts as six people on
welfare people with a full-time job is
actually does not count households so in
the same family
you would have six on the bar on the
left and one on the bar on the right
clearly giving a very different
impression right and so again pictures
can be good but if you don't dive deep
into them they really can fool you now
before I should leave this slide I
should say that it's not the case that
you can't believe anything you read on
Fox News because in fact the Red Sox did
beat the st. Louis Cardinals forwarded
to that day
so the moral here is to ask whether the
things being compared are actually
comparable are you really comparing
apples and oranges as they say okay this
is probably the most common statistical
sin it's called guy go and perhaps this
picture can tell you make you guess with
the Gees stand for guy go is garbage in
garbage out so here's a great again
quote about it so Charles Babbage
designed the first digital computer the
first actual computation engine he was
unable to build it but hundreds of years
after he died one was built according to
his design it had actually worked no
electronics really so he was a famous
person and he was asked by parliament
about his machine which he was asking
them to fund well if you put wrong
numbers into the machine will the
machine have right numbers come out the
other end and of course he was a very
smart guy and he was totally baffled
this question seemed so stupid he
couldn't believe it what anyone even
asked it that it was just computation
and the answers you get or based on the
data you put in he put in garbage you
get out garbage so here is an example
from the 1840s they did a census in the
1840s and for those of you who were not
familiar with American history it was a
very contentious time in the u.s. the
country was divided between states that
had slavery and states that didn't and
that was the dominant political issue of
the day John Calhoun who was Secretary
of State and a leader in the Senate was
from South Carolina and a strong
probably the strongest proponent
slavery and he used the sentence to
census data to say that slavery was
actually good for the slaves kind of an
amazing thought basically saying that
this data claimed that freed slaves were
more likely to be insane than enslaved
slaves he was rebooted in the sentence
Senate or in the house by John Quincy
Adams who had formerly been President of
the United States after he stopped being
President he ran for Congress from
Braintree Massachusetts actually now
called Quincy the party's from after his
family and he claimed that atrocious
misrepresentations have been made I'm a
subject of deep importance he was an
abolitionist so you don't even have to
look at statistics know who to believe
just look at these pictures right here
you know believe this nice gentleman
from Braintree or this scary guy from
South Carolina but setting that looks
aside calhoun eventually admitted that
the census was indeed full of errors but
he said that was fine because there were
so many of them that they would balance
each other out and lead to the same
conclusion as if they were all correct
so he didn't believe in garbage in
garbage out he said yeah it's really our
become out in the end okay well now we
know enough to ask the question this
isn't totally brain-dead and that we've
already looked at experiments and said
we get experimental error and under some
circumstances you can manage the error
right the data isn't garbage just as
errors but it's true if the measurement
errors are unbiased and independent of
each other and almost identically
distributed on either side of the mean
right that's why we spend so
I'm looking at the normal distribution
and why it's called Gaussian because
Gauss said yes I know I have errors in
my astronomical measurements but I
believe my errors are distributed in
what we now call a Gaussian curve and
therefore I can still work with them and
get an accurate estimate of the values
now of course that wasn't true here
the errors were not random they were in
fact quite systematic designed to
produce a certain thing and the last
word was from another abolitionist who
claimed it was the in census that was
insane
all right that's garbage in garbage out
the moral here is that analysis of bad
data is worse than no analysis at all
really right time and again we see
people doing actually often correct
statistical analysis of incorrect data
and reaching conclusions right and
that's really risky so before one goes
off and starts using statistical
techniques of the sort we've been
discussing the first question you have
to ask is is the data itself worth
analyzing and it often isn't now you
could argue that this is a thing of the
past and no modern politician would make
these kinds of mistakes
I'm not going to insert a photo here but
I leave it to you to think which
politicians photo you might paste in
this frame all right onto another
statistical thin is the picture of a
World War two fighter plane I don't know
enough about planes to know what kind of
plane it is anyone here must be an arrow
student who will be able to tell me what
plane this is don't they teach you guys
anything in error these days shame on
them all right anyway it's a plane that
much I know and it has a propeller and
that's all I can tell you about the
airplane so this was a photo taken at a
airfield in Britain
and the allies would send planes over
Germany for bombing runs fighters
protect the Bombers and when they came
back the planes are often damaged and
they would inspect the damage and say oh
look there's a lot of flak there the
Germans shot flak at the planes and that
would be a part of the plane that maybe
we should reinforce in the future so
when it gets hit by flak it survives it
does less damage
so you'd analyze where the Germans were
hitting the planes and you would add a
little extra armor to that part of the
plane what's the flaw in that yeah yeah
this is what's called in the jargon
survivor bias su r VI VOR the planes
they really should have been analyzing
were the ones that got shot down but
those were hard to analyze so they
analyzed the ones they had and drew
conclusions and perhaps totally the
wrong conclusion
maybe the conclusion they should have
drawn is well it's okay if you get hit
here let's reinforce the other places I
don't know enough to know what the right
answer was I do know that this was
statistically the wrong thing to be
thinking about doing and this is an
issue we have whenever we do sampling
all statistical techniques are based
upon the assumption that by sampling a
subset of the population we can infer
things about the population as a whole
right everything we've done this term
has been based on that when we were
fitting curves we were doing that when
we were talking about the empirical rule
and Monte Carlo simulation we were doing
that we were building models with
machine learning we were doing
and if random sampling is used you can
make meaningful mathematical statements
about the relation of the sample to the
entire population and that's why so many
should what we did works and when we're
doing simulations that's really easy
right when we were choosing random
values of the needles for trying to find
pi a random values the roulette wheel
spins we could be pretty sure our
samples were indeed random in the field
it's not so easy right because some
samples are much more convenient to
acquire than others much more it's much
easier to acquire a plane on the field
in Britain than a plane on the ground in
France convenience sampling as it's
often called is not usually random so
you have survivor bias so I all I asked
you to do course evaluations well
there's survivor bias they're the people
who really hated this course have
already dropped it and so we won't
sample them and that's good for me at
least but we see that we see that with
grades the people who are really
struggling who are most likely to fail
it probably dropped the course too
that's one of the reasons I don't think
it's fair to say we're going to have a
curve and we're going to always fail
this fraction and give a nays to this
fraction because by the end of the term
we have a lot of survivor bias the
students who are left are on average
better than the students who started the
semester so you need to take that into
the count another kind of non
representative sampling or convenience
sampling is opinion polls in that you
have something there called non-response
bias so I don't know about you but I get
phone calls asking my opinion about
things
surveys about products whatever I never
answer I just hang up the phone I get a
zillion emails every time I stay in a
hotel I get an email asking me to rate
the hotel when I fly I get emails from
the the airline I don't answer any of
those surveys but some people do or
presumably or they wouldn't send them
out but why should they think that the
people who answer the survey are
representative of all the people who
stay in the hotel or all the people who
fly in the plane they're not they're the
kind of people who maybe have time to
answer surveys and so you get an on rep
non-response bias and that tends to
distort your results when samples are
not random and independent we can still
run statistics on them we can compute
means and standard deviations and that's
fine but we can't draw conclusions using
things like the empirical rule or the
central limit theorem standard error
because the basic assumption underlying
all of that is that the samples are
random and independent this is one of
the reasons why political polls are so
unreliable they compute statistics using
standard error assuming that the samples
are random and independent but they for
example get them mostly by calling
landlines and so they get a bias towards
people who actually answer the phone on
a landline as opposed how many of you
have a landline where you live not many
right mostly you rely on your cell
phones right and so any survey that
depends on landlines is going to leave a
lot of the population out they'll get a
lot of people of of my Vintage not of
your vintage and that gets you in
trouble so the moral here is always
understand how the data was collected
what the
in the analysis were and whether they're
satisfied if these things are not true
you need to be very wary of the results
all right I think I'll stop here we'll
finish up our panoply of statistical
sins on Wednesday in the first half and
we'll do a course wrap-up then I wish
you all Godspeed and a good final see
you Wednesday